ينضم لنا من جبل اللوز بتبوك مراسل صباح
العربيه هاني صبيان ومنطقه الارز بالشمال
لبنان زميلارينا دويهي مراسله صباح
العربيه يسعد صباحكما اهلا بكم ويازين
عيشتكم هاني يسعد صباحك همم
تحديدا جبل اللوز يتوشاح بالبياض اليوم
2500 متر وصل سمك وارتفاع ثلوج هناك
حديثنا اكثر عن الاجواء كيف كانت
نعم اهلا وسهلا فيكم صباح الخير طبعا
تحديدا جبل اللوز اليوم هي تتبع منطقه
نيوم وهي المنطقه الجديده والمنطقه
الحالمين ومنطقه المستقبل واللي تستعد لها
السعوديه برده في هذا المكان اضافه الى
اماكن اخرى انها تستقبل وايضا تكون فيها
دوره الالعاب الشتويه لعام 20 29 الان
صراحه هذه المنطقه وعلى هذه القمه همم
هناك استعدادات كامله ولكن قبل ان نعرض او
نستعرض استعدادات راح استعرض يعني ما تبقى
من الثلوج طبعا يوم امس كان هناك كثافه
عاليه من الثلوج طبعا الان هذا ما تبقى من
الثلوج شيء قليل جدا لا يذكر طبعا هذا من
دائما من النوادر في قمه جبل اللوز فيني
نوم ان تكون تحدث لنا ظاهره او ظاهره
الثلجيه طبعا الثلج هذا العام وهنا في
المنطقه هذه سبق الموعد المحدد العادي
دائما 17 يناير
10 يناير تبدا تساقط الثلوج الاكل اليوم
اننا نشهد ان في اواخر ديسمبر تشهد قمه
جبل اللوز هنا في نيوم
التساقط الثلوج بشكل كبير طبعا ده درجه
الحراره الان هي درجه الحراره تقريبا تصل
او تلامس واحد درجه مئويه يوم امس كانت
وصلت الى اكثر من ثلاثه تحت الصفر يعني
درجه حراره هذه ايضا غير مشدوده وغير
متوقعه كم في وقت ديسمبر تحديدا وكما ذكرت
سابقا في يناير تبدا انخفاض في الدرجات
الحراره لكن خلينا نوريكم برده طبيعه
اليوم الجبليه وقمه جبل اللوز في اعلى قمه
يعني فريق صباح العربيه وصباح العربيه
كمان خلينا نشوف بمقلب اخر ونشوف بمنطقه
الارز بشمال لبنان رينو وبعدين بنرجع لك
لانه يعني ذا بالثلج وبانش في جبان في جبل
اللوز لكن
يلا يلا انا عارف انك تبوا انتم تطهدوني
بس يلا يلا
انت بمنطقه الارز بشمال لبنان معروفه
ومشهوره منطقه عاليه ومرتفعه بس بدي عندي
فضول اعرف طريقك لو وصلت اليوم كيف كانت
شو اللي اعترضك من صعوبات مطبات
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير صباح الخير مع هذا المشهد
الجميل الخلفي هذه اللي عم تشوفوها هي
الثلج الاول الثلوج الاولى لموسم الشتاء
الجديد طبعا الصعوبات يعني تتركز على
الجليد اللي يرافق الطرقات صباحا همم خلال
هذا المشوار لانه الجليد بخلال ساحات
الصباح الاولى قبل ما تطلع الشمس بعرض
للانزلاقات همم كثير نحن في منطقه الارز
اعلى قمم شمال لبنان على ارتفاع يفوق من
2500 متر وهنا ترون بعدسه الكاميرا غبت
الارز على اكتاف هذا الولد طبعا الثلوج
الموجوده الان هي ثلوج بسيطه وقارنه به
الثلوج التي تكثر هذه المنطقه الا ان
للزائر الابيض في هذه المناطق مكانه خاصه
في قلوب السكان ومعه يبدا موسم الرزق معه
مبدا يبدا موسم الشتاء الذي حيث تسدهر
السياحه الشتويه ومراكز التزلج هنا ولكنه
ايضا موسم ياتي ثقيلا في الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها لبنان كونه يعني
يحرم حتى القلوب ابناء المناطق هنا بسبب
ازمه الكهرباء والمحروقات الا ان للجنرال
الابيض همم قدره على همم يعني همم على بس
الامل رغم كل شيء كيف اقبال السياح يا
رينا على هذه المنطقه بالتحديد هم يحبوا
الثلوج الموسم الرعايه
طبعا التولوجيا يعني يحبها الكبار والصغار
هنا هلا لا استطيع ان نتكلم عن موسم من
انطلق حتى الان لان حتى مراكز التزلج لم
تفتح بعد هي تحتاج الى كثافه ثلوج اكثر
بكثير من التي نراها الان هذه الثلوج عاده
ما تاتي ثلج الاولى في هذا الموسم همم
يعني ما بين اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه الا
انها يعني معها مع نهايه العام همم تتكثف
اكثر ومعها يفتتح موسم التزلج الذي يعني
وبسبب همم كثير من العوامل قد تكون مرتبطه
بتغيرات الجيولوجيه عن سنه ولكن مع ذلك
همم يعني هذه المنطقه هنا تنتعش همم من
التزلج ومن السياحه الشتويه يعني انا بس
هيك اسمحي لي لفه صغيره
بلبنان من اللبن اللون الابيض لانه كان
لبنان هو الجبال المرتف كانت دائما تكسوها
البياض فمن هنا جاءت تسميه لبنان ريما انا
كمان عجبني كثير اللوك يعني لفته حلوه هيك
على الصبح فريحيك خلي لبستيها على راسك
كريدت
صراحه الله يخلي لك بنتك يا اسماء وانت
طالعه اصلا مثل بنتك هلا همم رهاني خلينا
نروح شوي لهاني لانه هاني انت السنه
الماضيه كان معنا بلايف كنا انا واياك
برده
كانت ثلج معبي الجبل وعملت لنا كمان همم
العرضه بس اليوم شكل الامور اهداء هل في
بعدين منخفضات يعني
ليه كده اعطيني حيويه شوي على شو اسمك
[موسيقى]
العام الماضي طبعا معروفه في الثلوج ورينا
لعلها تسمعنا يعني انه الارض دائما تكون
اول تكون مصاحبه لوقت الثلوج يعني فرحه
وبهجه بهذا الثلوج طبعا
الوقت النادر اللي تساقط فيه ثلوج هنا
تحديدا في قمه جبل اللوز في النجوم في
موعد يمكن لا يمكن هناك
لم نشهد برده عدد كثير من الزوار وايضا
السياح اللي كانوا موجودين بخلاف يوم امس
طبعا يوم امس كان تقريبا هذا المكان زي ما
اتذكرتي نادين كان يكسوه البياض بالكامل
اليوم نشاهد يعني اشعه الشمس بشكل قوي
ورغم من انخفاض في الدراجات الحراره لكن
خبراء الطقس والارصاد ايضا ما زالوا همم
يقومون بالتنبيهات اللازمه في الايام
المقبله لتساقط الثلوج سواء في قمه
اللوز في يوم او كذلك في منطقه تبوك او
كذلك في منطقه الحدود الشماليه يعني انا
اتخيلوا اكلمكم ليومين وان الفريق العربيه
ان نقوم بجوله على الحدود الشماليه قطعنا
حتى نصل الى هذا المكان اكثر من 1600 كيلو
متر بعبر المركبه مركبه السياره وصلنا الى
هذه المنطقه طبعا احنا شهدنا الامطار
الغزيره شاهدنا الامطار المتوسطه في
المنطقه الحدود الشماليين نتكلم عن
القريات رفحه طريف عرعر حزم الجلاميد
وصلنا تبوك وصلنا النجوم لكن ما كانت ايضا
همم فكره او تساقط الثلوج في جبل اللوز
كانت موجوده او كانت من ضمن التنبيهات
يعني كانت التنبيهات كلها رايحه للمدن
اللي احنا مريناها لكن كانت موجوده فيها
امطار وفي خلاف منطقه قمه جبل اللوز اللي
كانت خارج التوقعات وجهات الوجه يوم امس
يلا الحقنا على الكميه البسيطه اللي
قدامنا نلحقها ولكن برده رغم ان وجودنا
هنا راح نستغل برضه الاعمال الانشائيه
اللي تستعد فيها نيوم للالعاب الشتويه
التي سوف تستضيف السعوديه في 20 29 وهي
لاول مره طبعا براحتك تكون في وقت الشتاء
وفي نهايه ديسمبر وبي من الوقت يكون جيد
وبيمنى الموت يكون درجات حراره منخفضه
وكذلك
احتماليه تساقط الثلوج الى اضافه الى
المشاريع الثلجيه اللي راح تكون همم
اصطناعيه راح تقام في هذه المنطقه حتى
تكون مناسبه لهذه دوره الالعاب بياض
كلمه اخيره رينا عشان العدل والتوزيع
ما بتزعلي حدا نادين انت ما بتزعلي حدا
ويسعد صباحكم
الجديده في السعوديه بكل الاحوال اكيد
بنروح كلنا مع بعض ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]